when Mexico sends its people they're not
sending their best they're bringing
drugs they're bringing crime they're
rapists I'm putting the people on notice
that are coming here from Syria as part
of this mass migration that if I win if
I win they're going back there going
back I'm telling you they're going back
if you had 25 people in there that had
guns okay would have been a totally
different story folks that would have
been the shootout at the ok corral right
and you would have had death but it
would have been their death written by a
nice reporter now the poor guy you got
to see this guy oh I don't know what I
said ah I don't remember he's gonna like
I don't remember either oh baby that's
what I said